pourquoi parce qu' hierier est sorti en
salle le film Bernadette consacré à
Bernadette Chirac la femme de l'ancien
président Jacques Chirac l'occasion pour
nous de parler de la vie des femmes de
on dit toujours que derrière un grand
homme il une grande femme non c'est ça
oui mais je peux vous confirmer que oui
c'est le cas mais on le sait pas
toujours bon on le sait pas toujours et
vous vous le savez pourquoi vous avez
écrit de livres le couloir de de Madame
à propos sur Brigitte Macron al Brigitte
Macron pénéope Fillon Béatrice Galard
qui était la femme de de Benoît amont
Louis alot qui à l'époque était le
compagnon de Marine Le Pen enfin tous
ceux qui allaient rentrer dans l'ombre
et dans le couloir de Madame c'est comme
ça qu'on appelle l'aile de l'Élysée où
il y a le bureau de la première dame
voilà et ça donc vous connaissez tous
les secrets les coulisses et la
frondeuse avec christop jacubizine sur
Valérie trière valeur d'abord vous
l'avez vu le film qui l'a vu
malheureusement non tu l'as vu oui moi
je l'ai vu je l'ai vu je l'ai vu hier
soir bah c'est c'est un très bon film
Catherine deu on la voit pour la
première fois dans dans dans un rôle un
peu comique qui lui va très bien je
trouve et puis on voit le glowup si je
peux me permettre cet anglicisme de de
de Bernad des Chirac où elle passe d'une
femme de l'ombre une femme où où on est
dans un paysage politique un peu
matchiste à une femme qui s'affirme et
qui devient la star et qui permet même à
Jacques Chirac d'être élu pour un un un
quinena le premier après en en 2002
alors ce qui nous amusit beaucoup et
vous allez nous raconter Alix Bernadet
Chirac CIT c'est quelqu'un de très
particulier qui n'a pas la langue dans
sa poche euh et qui euh qui savait
tacler euh la personne qui se trouvait
en face d'elle ah oui c'était euh
une elle était oui bon enfin je parle de
cette époque elle est lisaé c'est un
personnage euh qui est euh extrêmement
rche euh qui peut être extrêmement
désagréable mais qui a un côté aussi
extrêmement à qui vous en avez fait les
frais qui peut être drôle c'est-à-dire
qu'elle a beaucoup d'humour oui euh
alors pas moi personnellement mais j'ai
une petite anecdote d'un ancien
chauffeur de de Jacques Chirac c'était à
l'époque où il habitait k vololtaire
c'était l'hiver il y avait son chauffeur
et quelques gardes du corps qui
attendaient en bas et là Jacques Chirac
plutôt dans dans la bonomie qu'on lui
connaît propose qu'on a qu'on amène des
cafés au chauffeurs et etgard du corps
et là il y a Bernadette qui dit ah non
non on apporte pas le café c'est pas
nous d'All leur apporter le café des
anecdotes comme ça quoi donc pou rche
effectivementa ah oui sympa euh mais
mais il y a deux temps quand même dans
le personnage de Bernadette il y a la
femme de l'ombre celle qui est une tête
bien pleine et bien faite hein qui est
la sciencep avec Jacques chira qui lui
fait ses fiches qui l'aide et qui
l'accompagne et qui accepte finalement
d'être cette femme de l'ombre pendant
toute une période quand quand il est
député quand il est à la mairie de Paris
quand il arrive à l'Élysée et
effectivement quand elle arrive à
l'Élysée il est élu en 95 sur la
fracture sociale et elle c'est une
aristocratique c'est Bernadette chudron
de Courcel elle va pas du tout dans dans
le décor et la première fois qu'elle se
rend compte que ça va être compliqué
pour elle elle qui par rapport aux
autres premières dames arrivai avec
beaucoup de bonheur à l'Élysée elle
s'est rendu compte que ça alla être
compliqué c'est le 14 juillet 95 il y a
Jacques Pillan qui à l'époque est le
grand ordonnateur de la communication
que jaces shirac décide d'organiser un
déjeuner avec des jeunes Jacques Chirac
Madame Chirac et des jeunes et là il dit
non il faut que Bernadette disparaisse
de la photo parce que sinon c'est papas
maman et les enfants ça va pas du tout
et à partir de là
rentre en en pant un qu ah oui alors moi
j'ai une anecdote à VSD on voulait faire
la Une c'est Philippe Lab qui dirigeait
le service politique la une avec Bernad
il voulait faire la une avec Bernadette
Claude et Jacques et Jacques dit
pourquoi Bernadette Claude et moi ça
suffit et alors bah Philippe désespéré
dit à Bernadette Chirac je suis désolé
mais je voudrais quand même vous soyz
sur la photo comment le convaincre elle
dit non non vous inquiétez pas pour qu'
a une photo de famille il faut qu'il y
ait une famille et donc là c'était
terrible ah oui c'était cash et c'est
vrai qu'elle pouvait être très très dur
moi je l'ai vu à France Télévision où
elle détestait le patron de France
Télévision qu'elle trouvait trouvait mal
habillé et tout et tout et il est allé
vers la voiture elle le trouvait
obséquieux en plus il allait vers la
voiture pour lui rendre hommage il un
documentaire sur elle et elle dit
démarrez démarrez et elle remonte la
vitre à toute vitesse et s'est coincer
les doigts dans la dans la glace de la
voiture et ben c'est bien fait elle elle
elle était elle avait des inimitiés et
en politique également c'est-à-dire
qu'il y en avait un qu'elle ne pouvait
pas supporter parce que elle avait du
pif Bernadette elle a vu des choses 2002
Jean-Marie Le Pen au second tour elle
l'a vu la dissolution de 97 elle a
toujours trouvé que c'était une énorme
connerie si je puis me permettre et le
soir de la victoire de la gauche et et
donc de cette dissolution totalement
ratée elle arrive il y a une forme de
fête qui est plutôt une veillée
funéraire elle arrive en disant il est
où Néron Néron étant Dominique de
Villepin qui était le grand ordonnateur
le le grand cerveau derrière cette
dissolution alors ça c'est pour
Bernadette Chirac mais aujourd'hui par
exemple Brigitte Macron alors Brigitte
Macron effectivement on commente encore
aujourd'hui je sais pas si c'est encore
d'actualité mais c'est tenu son look
c'est quoi son rôle exactement à
Brigitte Macron Brigitte Macron elle
elle a une chance c'est finalement
d'être arrivé à l'Élysée à un moment où
elle était retraitée de l'éducation
nationale et elle n'a pas eu ce choix
très cruel qu'on eu certaines
précédentes premières dam je pense à
Valérie trveller qui était une
journaliste active et qui s'est retrouvé
jeune l'Élysée en se disant mon Dieu
qu'est-ce que je vais faire de moi je ne
suis pas une femme deux et à qui les
hommes de l'Élysée parce que honnêtement
ê première dame c'est c'est un c'est
c'est pas un champ de rose les hommes du
président ils ont pas du tout être envie
d'être embêtés avec la première Dam et
les état dames d'une première dame donc
ils en ont rien à faire donc la première
dame elle se démerde toute seule et
doncour des ass de
collaborateursorateur ouis enfin ça
dépend des premières dames il y en a qui
ont eu plus ou moins mais Valérie
trveller ça a été une grande solitude
quand elle est arrivée finalement elle
se dit mais il est où le petit manuel
pour m'expliquer comment je vais être
première dame et ben non elle se
débrouille toute seule elle a beaucoup
parlé avec Carla Bruny Sarkozi qui elle
a vécu ça de
manière en fait elle a fait le deuil
d'elle-même pendant 5 ans elle a été
d'une discrétion absolue elle a fait la
potiche
parfaite mais oui parce que c'est vrai
que là on est en train de débattre de la
première dame mais pourquoi ne peut-on
pas considérer que c'est une citoyenne l
regardez le le le mari de d'Angela
merkelim enfin personne ne connaît qui
il est c'est un prof de chimie il fait
sa vie pourquoi c'est pas comme fr
apparitions dont un à l'Opéra une fois
l'an mais parce que les femmes de de les
premières dames elles ont quand même un
rôle social elles ont elles accompagnent
leur mari elles reçoivent beaucoup de
courriers elles n'ont pas de budget donc
elles se retrouvent encore sous la coupe
du budget de l'Élysée il y a pas de
statut juridique à la première dame donc
elles ont un rôle impossible et pour
revenir à à Brigitte Macron elle a de la
chance sa vie professionnelle était
derrière elle elle a accompagné Emmanuel
Macron et elle arrive euh a finalement
endossé ce rôle qui est un rôle INR et
c'est c'est là où je trouve Brigitte
Macron qui est un peu la succession de
de Bernadette Chirac parce que au-delà
de d'avoir repris les pièges jaunes
parce que c'est vrai que Bernadette
était aussi aimé pour ça pour pour pour
les opérations sociales Brigit Macron a
repris un peu ce rôle là et puis elle a
une influence politique si Carla Bruni
était un peu dans la discrétion BR
Macron elle elle a quand même une
influence politique par exemple on sait
que pour le recrutement de Jean-Michel
blankerer ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est elle qui a conseillé au
président donc elle a quand même une
influence ce qu'avait aussi Bernadette
Chirac je pas si vous rappelez de cette
scène où il y a Jacques Chirac qui
drague une une une conseillre réale
bernir qui se retourne tu veux toi donc
audelà au-delà d'avoir du de la poigne
sont aussi des femmes qui ont de
l'influence à ce sujet d'ailleurs
bernanette chir était tout à fait
consciente des comment dire les
frivolités pas de côté de son mari
justement comment elle passe du premier
mandat au deuxème mandat c'est un livre
qui a été pour elle une cararcis qu'elle
écrit et qui s'appelle ation avec
Patrick de Carolis et là elle elle font
l'armure et là elle
explique ses souffrances ses aspirations
ses envies effectivement son mari qui
l'a trompé allaigrement comment elle a
pris sur elle comment elle s'est endurci
et là ça devient une superstar
Bernadette et elle
est elle est faiseuse de de roi à un
moment parce que même dans les meetings
de
l'UMP le deuxè mandat elle est hyper
populaire et donc elle soutient être
avoir Bernadette dans une salle c'est
très important et et elle a un coup de
cœur formidable pour Nicolas Sarkozi
elle digère le la cassure baladure
Chirac elle et elle est la seule à
effectivement après se dire Nicolas
Sarkozi ça va être lui et et elle le
elle le défendra bec et ongle tout le
temps et et Sarkozi était le premier
président à pipoliser un peu les
premières dames parce que quand il
divorce de de Cécilia au début de son
mandat quelques mois après il est en
conférence de presse il fait avec avec
Carla c'est du
sérieux très bien très très fort
le couple le couple et Carla brun
c'était la première fois où on pipolise
un peu la première dame et donc ça
devient une star quand même ou ouais
mais Nicolas disait de a dit récemment
Nicolas qui s excusenous sais pas c'est
un
am je pense finalement en y
réfléchissant bien que Jacques Chirac
avait plus besoin de Bernadette que
Bernadette de Jacques oui bien sûr oui
oui c'était c'était quand même un pilier
alors c'est vrai que c'est aussi une
ascension hyper classique mais c'est
mais c'est une femme qui a réussi
finalement après à prendre le dessus et
qui effectivement maîtrisait son mari et
et sans lui il était rien d'ailleurs
chaque fois qu'il était quelque part il
elle est où donc il ait la tortue la
fameuse tortue qui avait toujours un un
MRE de RET c'est sympa la tortue on
parler de sa femme c'est charmant ça et
elle a eu sa petite revanche en en 2017
euh présidentielle Nicolas Sarkozi face
à François Hollande on sait que dans la
famille Chirac tout le monde déteste
Nicolas Sarkozi parce que effectivement
c'est c'est le traître et elle et elle
dira allègrement à tout Paris que dans
la famille tout le monde a voté pour
François Hollande mais qu'elle elle
avait une procuration elle votait pour
Jacques Chirac et elle disait sauf mon
mari mais qui ne le sait pas donc elle a
voté pour Nicolas Sarkozi ah oui ah oui
oui oui donc elle envoyé des petites PS
par derrière et peutêtre un mot sur
Valérie trivaler qui est arrivé un petit
peu aussi dans des conditions un peu
particulières euh on s'en souvient
c'était peu compliqué puis il y a eu
l'épisode du scooter ça étit très
compliqué parce que en fait
contrairement à Nicolas Sarkozi qui a
extrêmement protégé Cécilia en arrivant
déjà il l'a épousé immédiatement au bout
de 5 mois ils étaient ensemble à
l'Élysée c'était une manière aussi de la
protéger euh François Hollande a pas eu
cette enfin pas fait ce choix-là
vis-à-vis de valirur qui s'est senti
effectivement très seul et qui n'a pas
réussi qui voulait faire quelque chose
et d'ailleurs moi quand je le j'ai écrit
le livre sur elle elle avait l'intention
de s'inscrire peut-être dans un un truc
un peu traditionnel peut-être une
fondation mais en même temps elle avait
trois enfants euh elle était pas mariée
à François Hollande et et elle s'est dit
mais moi je peux pas lâcher mon job
pendant 5 ans qu'est-ce que je deviens
dans 5 ans qui va nourrir mes enfants
donc on l'a mise dans une situation
impossible elle n'était pas protégé et
d'où les complications qui ont suivi ben
Val treviler c'est la première dame à
souligné qu'il y a une hypocrisie au
niveau du statut vous disiez tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait pas de statut de
première dame en 2017 Emmanuel Macron
c'est le premier président qui a mis en
place une charte de la transparence avec
plusieurs missions la représentation de
la France au côté du président le
soutien aux actions caritatives répondre
au courriers tout ça ça ça existait pas
avant et même maintenant le budget qui
est alloué entre guillemets à la
première dame est publique par exemple
pour Brigitte Macron on sait que ça
représente 0,28 % du budget de l'Élysée
35 35000
€ 35000 € mais c'est mais c'est un peu
de la poudre aux yeux parce que ça reste
le budget de l'Élysée donc monsieur
décide d'attribuer une pe madame c'est
qu même incroyable non mais c'est quand
même incroyable on est en 2023 il y a
que nous qui fonctionnant comme ça ou ça
marche comme ça l'étranger non ça marche
pas comme ça l'étranger parce que dans
beaucoup de pays il y a un statut
justement de la Première Dame aux
États-Unis c'est extrêmement extrêmement
réglementé euh à l'époque Michel Obama
elle avait vraiment son staff son budget
euh et puis euh elle s'inscrivait dans
des causes euh voilà il y avait une
forme de récurrence Michel Obama c'était
la lutte contre l'obésité euh c'était
aussi le lien avec les femmes de de
militaire non c'est là-bas c'est
orchestré c'est cadré en France c'est le
bazar il faut que ça change quand même
là où c'est encore d'ailleurs la vieille
école en France c'est qu'il faut que le
Président de la République soit marié
avec sa compagne c'està-dire que si
c'est une relation pas légal il y a
aucune obligation mais pour les voyages
diplomatiques en l'occurrence parfois la
compagne ne va pas forcément accompagner
le président de la républ premier voyage
de François Hollande premier déplacement
il est élu président il va aux
États-Unis et là si
la presse est totalement déboussolée
comment on va l'appeler on peut pas
l'appeler de First Lady donc on
l'appelle the first girlfriend ah bon ah
oui quand d'ailleurs quand ils ont
divorcé d'ailleurs juste après avoir
divorcé après cette séparé de Valérie
trweiler on voit effectivement François
Hollande qui doit faire un voyage aux
États-Unis et qui est entouré de Michel
Obama et Barack Obama et lui il est tout
seul donc même en terme d'image
d'ailleurs quand le président est
célibataire c'est assez particulier oui
ouais bon voilà donc pour pour enfin
nous il va falloir que ça bouge un peu
peut-être en France quoi l'envelot donné
par par l'ésée pas vraiment de statut
enfin voilà c'est un peu poussiéreux
tout ça non voilà un peu poussiéreux va
voir en 2027 qui sera à cette place là
vous avez une idée
non vous allez pas vous engager sur C
vous avez bien raison tout peu pourquoi
pas un homme oui pourquoi pas un homme
une femme a é élu président ça ou oui
exactement peut-être
qu' je sais pas qui c'estou pour l'inant
oui on sait pas on sait pas en tout cas
ça se dessine pas mais tout peut se
passer dans les 6 derniers mois on l'a
déjà vu